what two years did the Phillies win the
World Series 80 and 08
1980 and 2008 who did the Phillies beat
in the 08 World Series the race Tampa
Bay Ray who is the last Phillies player
to be named NL MVP Bryce Harper Chase
Utley how many home runs has Bryce
Harper scored so far this year's
postseason I believe it is number four
three what Eagles player was in the
stadium last night kelse Kelsey was one
of them with his brother what
Philadelphia Philly Allstar became a US
senator oh I don't know oh that was Jim
bunny who else is in the NL East
Division Marlins the Nationals the Mets
and the Braves that would be the New
York muts and we'll call the Atlanta
Braves the Braves I guess because we're
beating them so bad they don't deserve a
bad pick game those Florida Marlins and
then the Washington Nationals